Hello
Freak bitches speaking and dying.
Tell me about any culture.
Oh yeah,
that's what I'm dealing with all day.
So the sand culture situation and
Coulter was at the roasted rob Lowe.
It wasn't live right
and I was on last night,
but when did it,
when did they film it?
Last Saturday.
So we'll only a week away.
Yeah.
So what happened?
Well,
you know,
this is the sixth roasts that I've
written for the third one that I've been a
staff writer on.
And it's always interesting
when someone gets booked,
you know,
what's going to happen,
blah,
blah.
And Ann Coulter was one of the last
bookings that we had and I was excited to
help her.
And she,
uh,
she didn't want,
she didn't want to do anything
that the writers told her,
you know,
that she sorta had to do like to be funny.
And she's like,
she didn't think anything was funny.
So she rewrote everything.
Like the script that we
originally wrote anyway,
she bombed really bad.
She bombed really bad.
But what was she trying to avoid?
Like when you said she didn't want
to do what they wanted her to do?
Well,
we wanted her to write,
we won.
We had stuff in her voice,
like with her angle and a little
bit of self deprecating at the top.
You know what I mean?
Like it was supposed to be like,
Hey,
I'm Ann Coulter.
You know,
you might be wondering why I'm
here at the Rob Lowe Roast.
It's because it's the first time that I'm
not the most hated person in the room.
You know,
like sorta like put it on her lender
and you got to acknowledge who you are.
But instead she's like,
Nah,
I don't like that.
I'm not going to,
not going to play.
I'm not going to sell from,
am I going to shit on myself as sub rose?
Why would I do that?
You know?
There's no way there's no,
I mean that's,
those were her exact words,
but she just said she wasn't going to
do that and she would just cut out.
You Go,
you go back and forth via emails and then
all of a sudden all the good stuff is
cut out and there's bad stuff and
some of the stuff's rewritten.
Did you meet her in real life?
Yeah.
Did you meet her in real life before
the actual roast or the day of?
Uh,
the day of,
I talked to her on the
phone five days out,
which she was okay on that.
She's like laughing at the script,
but then once it's an email,
you know,
she rewrote it and it was bad.
But you really think that
she's less hated and Rob Lowe?
No.
No,
not at all.
Everyone looks rob Lowe,
who was the most hated person in the
room besides her was the joke about rob
Lowe.
Yeah.
The choke is like,
yeah,
no,
she's saying that she's hated.
She's acknowledging exactly it.
Then she's saying the Rob Lowe's hated.
So it's a joke,
but it's not really,
that part doesn't need to be funny though.
We just needed her to acknowledge that
she's a piece of shit and she didn't want
to do that.
Instead she came out and literally it's
like you might be wondering loyal I'm
here or it couldn't possibly
be to promote my new book.
And she leans down all awkwardly and
pulls out her shitty book in Trump.
We trust he pluribus awesome.
And she says,
I like it
plural.
Wait a minute,
wait a minute,
wait a minute.
Her new book
is in Trump.
We trust.
Yeah.
Wait for it.
E pluribus.
Awesome.
That's like the tag of the book.
Wow.
And she said it and just the roar,
this crowd book,
she loves Trump and on that
Trump shit money she wrote,
that is her 11th book.
She's written 11 books.
He's worth good amount of money.
Jesus Christ.
What was the purpose of having
her on the roast to begin with?
It seems like the roads
have always had like,
I kind of like a goat,
you know like Jersey shore.
They had the situation on tron
roast and hold that back up.
I want to read this
description but pull up,
make it smaller.
So yeah,
here we go.
Donald Trump isn't a politician.
He's a one man wrecking ball against
our dysfunctional and corrupt
establishment.
We're about to see the deluxe version of
the left's favorite theme volt for us,
or we'll call you stupid.
It's the working class against this
smirking class now Ann Coulter with her
unique insight,
candor and sense of humor,
who makes the definitive case for why
we should all join his revolution.
Wow.
She just bent over.
She bent over for the man who might
be king.
Yeah,
she was.
She know she wants to play that character,
but well if he wins and
she wrote a book like that,
she's in deep,
deep,
deep.
She be the one to defend him every
time there's any sort of a public,
you know,
he doesn't like her by the way.
He doesn't like her.
It doesn't like to see in.
One of the really funny things is that
he changed his immigration policy,
like tweak the tone of it the
day before that book came out.
And it's sorta like
mess things up because,
yeah,
because he's sorta like a office
books like all about like,
yeah,
don't let anybody in his zero immigration.
And he was sorta just like,
you know,
he visited Mexico like outta nowhere.
Like the day before her book
came out and she's like,
ah,
you know,
it just wasn't good press
for back to Ann Coulter.
Yeah.
So silly bitch.
So what does she try to do?
She tries to write her own jokes then.
Yeah,
there's,
you know,
like I worked with Martha Stewart for
the Bieber roast and she crushed it.
Crushed it.
First thing she said to me,
it was,
I want to kill as hard as I can.
So Hook it up and I'm like,
Stuart's done time.
That's what I want you to do.
Yeah.
She's the best ever.
She's been in the pokey.
She understands shit.
And at a level and Coulter where they're
privileged lifestyle of white people
everywhere she goes.
Correct.
And so Ann Coulter basically says that,
you know,
she doesn't like this joke.
She doesn't like that joke.
She writes this,
she puts a pitch for a book at the top.
First off,
she was like a third to last.
She was second.
So Rob Lowe,
when Ann Coulter,
Jeff Ross,
Rob Lowe,
and to show,
right.
So all these people in
before Ralph Machio,
Nikki Glaser,
Pete Davidson,
Jimmy Carr,
uh,
blah,
blah.
Anyway,
and she got lit up and I mean big time,
Peyton Manning,
jewel,
everybody,
they'd hit everybody
on the day as you know,
cause you always make fun of
everybody at a roast of course.
And then you get the main
target at the end of your thing.
But when people went in on Ian Coulter,
they went in hard,
very hard like Jimmy Card,
this one joke,
which I loved,
which I'm going to completely,
you know,
destroy right now because I
don't know exactly how he set up,
but it was something like Ann Coulter
was here and you ugly ratchet faced piece
of shit,
scum buckets,
like something like that.
Just like that.
Five insulting words,
just Cag,
Cag in a gang.
And he goes,
you are one of the most insufferable
human beings on the planet,
but it's not too late.
You can change,
you could kill yourself.
And the crowds about him,
I mean,
just everybody hated her.
So she was great to have on the Deus.
Wow.
She could have killed me.
And Mike Lawrence,
who's a huge pro wrestling
fan and Sarah Tiana,
who's an old school pro wrestling fan,
we looked at her like,
wow,
we can write her as a heel,
she'll own it,
it'll be great.
We're all going to look like superstars
because we were able to make Ann Coulter
funny.
But instead halfway through
the week we realize like,
oh no,
she doesn't get it and she wants to do
this and you don't want to scare away
from not being on the roast.
You know what I mean?
You don't want to be like,
hey,
you're going to hear going to do terrible
cause then there's a chance that you
might not do it.
And we wanted it there cause you know
you going to show she's going to do good,
great.
Everybody's gonna Shit on her.
But also,
you know,
worst comes to worse.
People love a train wreck
and this was a train wreck.
Super trainer was like,
no,
this was like a Gif of a train wreck.
It just got to watch it.
Boom,
boom.
She was terrible.
And the one thing comedy central did do,
which is hilarious,
is the reaction shots that they chose
for her jokes like when she was on stage,
uh,
are hilarious.
Like it just cuts to just,
people just started just studying.
Well,
yes,
he made
her bones in the safest,
softest world,
which is the world of like political
commentary where there's five different
people and everybody's shouting over
everybody and you don't have to say
anything that's really relevant.
Right.
And especially her,
because she's just a button pusher.
She's a white lady,
button pusher and she gets up there and
she says crazy things like if Canada
doesn't like it will invade them.
Yeah.
She says stupid shit like that,
that she doesn't even mean,
you know,
and like this is what she does.
She pushes buttons and Bill Maher calls
or his friend and they laugh together.
Hahahahaha and she
lives in the soft world.
That world that she stepped into is
not just one of the hardest worlds,
but for a person like her to go on after
someone like Jimmy Carr and get Kirra
washed and then attempt to plug
her book and all that Jazz.
Like I bet she has no idea what the
average person's perception her is because
she's dealing with that bubble,
that fucking talk show
and two d c crazy idea.
It's,
yeah.
But that weird bubble where she's kind
of legitimate in that bubble and you
know,
she's the button pusher.
I'll hear it was come crazy an yeah.
You know,
she thinks she's wacky.
And another thing is,
you know,
one of the main things that are
roast is when you get made fun of,
you should laugh.
Yeah.
Cause it shows that you
have a sense of humor.
That's like the main thing.
That's why Trump did it.
Now he's could be president.
Charlie Sheen did it.
Pro Trump can be president
because he did a roast.
Hey
Justin Bieber's the number one
artist in the world most blah.
Oh,
it's all gross.
Yeah.